tempo fa il giornalista massimo
gramellini e pubblicava un brevissimo ma
illuminante pezzo sulla stampa in cui
raccontava di un nonno che aveva
conservato in cantina uno scatolone
pieno di lampadine ormai bruciate perché
assolutamente convinto che in futuro si
sarebbe trovato il modo per ripararle il
giornalista si chiedeva dunque quando e
perché abbiamo smesso di credere nel
nostro futuro
forse abbiamo smesso di credere nel
nostro futuro quando abbiamo smesso di
credere nella scienza la storia si sa va
a cicli nel 1818 mary shelley scrisse
questo libro che secondo me incarna
perfettamente il passaggio da
illuminismo e romanticismo dalla fiducia
nella scienza tipica dell'illuminismo
alla visione negativa che invece della
scienza aveva il romanticismo
qui lo scienziato è visto come un folle
e la scienza come qualcosa di mostruoso
è pericoloso
ebbene dopo i grandi progressi
scientifici e tecnologici del novecento
oggi siamo di nuovo in un periodo buio
per la scienza
ho deciso quindi di condividere con voi
questa sera una riflessione circa i
passi da compiere per poter ricominciare
a guardare al nostro futuro con
ottimismo
il primo passo consiste sicuramente nel
dire un forte no alla pseudo scienza
perché ho detto che siamo di nuovo al
buio lontani dai lumi della ragione
perché la società è sempre più scettica
nei confronti della scienza ai suoi
metodi e si affida sempre più spesso a
ciarlatani e imbroglioni potrei parlarvi
del recentissimo caso stamina o delle
tante cure miracolose
col cancro che chissà perché secondo
alcuni vengono tenute nascoste ma invece
ho deciso di raccontarvi qualcosa che
ormai è storia
la tragica storia del ddt vedete il
diritti è stato il primo insetticida
moderno e a partire dal 1939 esso è
stato usato su larga scala per
combattere la malaria come risultati
strepitosi
al punto che nel 1948 esso valsa il
premio nobèl al suo inventore paul
muller i fatti appunto parlano da soli
in sri lanka per esempio si passò da 3
milioni di casi di malaria all'anno
prima dell'uso del diritto a soli 18 e
la national academy of science ha
stimato che il ddt in meno di due
decenni è stato in grado di salvare la
vita a 500 milioni di persone
ma cosa accade accade che nel 1962 una
biologa americana a che il carson
scrisse il libro primavera silenziosa
silent spring divenuto un best seller
nel quale sostiene che il ddt sia
pericoloso per l'ambiente ma soprattutto
che sia un cancerogeno per l'uomo
l'opinione pubblica allarmata cominciò
ad esercitare forti pressioni e l'idea
che il ddt fosse davvero estremamente
pericoloso per la salute dell'uomo
divenne un dato di fatto senza tuttavia
nessuna prova scientifica a sostegno di
questo i governi sulla spinta
dell'opinione pubblica e nonostante il
parere contrario degli scienziati
decisero di metterlo al bando con
conseguenze drammatiche in sudafrica si
abbia un aumento del mille per cento dei
casi di malaria e si stima che la messa
al bando del ddt abbia causato finora la
morte di 50 milioni di persone
e ancora oggi nel mondo di malaria muore
un bambino ogni minuto in tanto in tanto
la scienza è andata avanti e ha prodotto
i suoi dati i fatti e ha dimostrato che
il ddt non è un cancerogeno
al punto che recentemente
all'organizzazione mondiale della sanità
ha dichiarato che il ddt si può
utilizzare perché non è pericoloso per
la salute dell'uomo
a questo punto chiediamoci quanto ci è
costato questo errore
questa strage silenziosa poteva essere
evitata ma io penso di sì se si fosse
stati in grado di distinguere tra vero e
falso tra scienza e pseudo scienza
ricordandosi che la prima si basa su
fatti mentre la seconda su opinioni e
attenzione perché in questi giorni
stiamo ricadendo negli stessi errori con
la storia dei vaccini di nuovo
assistiamo pericolosamente ai fatti che
vengono calpestati dalle opinioni
ma come fare quindi a distinguere un
fatto da una menzogna
beh nello stesso modo in cui
distinguiamo un quadro falso da uno vero
solo attraverso la conoscenza se io non
conoscessi leonardo il suo stile la sua
pittura non sarei assolutamente in grado
di dire quale tra questi due dipinti sia
l'originale
ecco dunque che la strada per capire se
ci stanno mentendo
se ci stanno vendendo fumo passa
attraverso un avvicinamento alla scienza
che i suoi metodi e questo mi porta
immediatamente al secondo passo da
compiere per riconquistare il nostro
futuro
bisogna aumentare il capitale
scientifico del nostro paese in europa
da anni viene monitorato l'alfabetismo
scientifico attraverso una serie di
domande che vengono poste alla
popolazione
il sole è un pianeta gli antibiotici
uccidono virus e batteri l'elettrone è
più piccolo dell'atomo
ebbene solo il 60 per cento degli
italiani è in grado di fornire una
risposta corretta contro oltre l'ottanta
per cento degli svedesi e questo
significa che due italiani su cinque non
sanno che il sole è una stella o che gli
antibiotici servono solo a combattere le
infezioni batteriche
in italia solo il 3 per cento della
popolazione conosce il metodo
scientifico contro il 78 per cento dei
finlandesi
siamo quindi un paese scientificamente
analfabeta nelle scuole ma già a partire
dalle scuole elementari
bisognerebbe investire molto più tempo
nell'insegnamento del metodo scientifico
perché solo attraverso un esercizio
costante all'analisi razionale dei fatti
si potrà poi sviluppare quella capacità
di affrontare e risolvere i problemi
usando la logica la mancanza di capitale
scientifico nel nostro paese si riflette
nel basso numero di ricercatori che
abbiamo in italia il numero di
ricercatori in percentuale sulla
popolazione è molto più basso che in
francia in germania e non a caso questo
dato correla con la percentuale di
investimenti rispetto al pil
terzo e ultimo passo quindi per poter
aumentare il capitale scientifico del
nostro paese
distinguere così tra vero e falso e
guardare di nuovo al futuro con
ottimismo e investire nella ricerca ma
in particolare nella slot science la
ricerca di base ricerca di base che si
sa non va più di moda e del resto è
normale che
una società che abbia smesso di credere
nel proprio futuro non sia minimamente
interessata alla ricerca di base le cui
ricadute non sono mai immediate in un
mondo dominato dalla fretta fatto di
fast food anche a scapito della qualità
fast news anche a scapito delle fonti
ecco che si chiede anche alla ricerca
scientifica di essere fast veloce
finalizzata applicata è pronta a mettere
sul mercato un prodotto e ci si
dimentica troppo spesso che la ricerca
applicata altro non è che l'applicazione
della ricerca di base ma tutte le grandi
idee sono nate grazie al gioco alla
curiosità alla continua partita a
scacchi che appunto noi ricercatori
giochiamo ogni giorno con la natura rent
game di certo non pensava alla
mammografia quando giocando ha scoperto
i raggi ics così come di sicuro einstein
non aveva in mente il gps quando
studiava la relatività ci sono voluti
molti anni prima di trovare le
applicazioni pratiche a queste enormi
scoperte scientifiche mosse soltanto
dalla curiosità
rivendichiamo quindi il diritto a
giocare a prenderci tutto il tempo che
ci serve a non twittare i risultati dei
nostri esperimenti a sbagliare
confrontarci e ammettere di aver
sbagliato
rivendichiamo il diritto alla lentezza
ad una scienza accurata libera da
pressioni e svincolata dal mercato
abbiamo iniziato questa chiacchierata
con una lampadina rotta simbolo però di
un futuro luminoso perché noi questa
lampadina la vogliamo riparare la
scienza non è un nemico
grazie ad essa la vita media dell'uomo è
passata da 38 anni
83 e questo è stato possibile solo
grazie al progresso scientifico e
tecnologico del novecento perché lì che
in pochissimi anni la vita media è quasi
raddoppiata e ancora oggi grazie al
progresso della scienza la mortalità
infantile per cancro per infezioni
continuano a diminuire e dunque in
questo futuro migliore che noi dobbiamo
e vogliamo continuare a credere in un
nuovo illuminismo che poi l'arma
migliore che possiamo usare in questi
giorni bui contro chi vuole farci
ripiombare in un violento e assurdo
medioevo